نقلت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه عن رئيس
هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه محمد اسلامي
قوله ان لدى طهران منظومه الدفاع جوي قويه
لحمايه منشاتها وانها مستعده لشالي اي
هجمات
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اجروسي
لايران تحتاج لاهداف وبرامج واضحين ونوبها
اسلامي الى ان ايران بدات بتشغيل خط انتاج
تجربه لينتاج النظائر المستقره وهي احدى
العمليات والمتوازيه والبديله لانتاج
الادويه الاشعاعيه في مجال السرطان وعلاج
الغده الدرقيه
المواقف والتصريحات التي نسمعها من الدول
الغربيه هي ذاتها المواقف التي تتبناها
اسرائيل وتكرها خلال العامين الماضيين نفذ
مفاتشون وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الفي
عمليه تفتيش 500 منها كانت في ايران ورغم
ذلك يعبرون عن قلقهم اذا برنامجنا النووي
وهذا دليل على انهم يتبنون مواقف العدو
هذه تحركات تخريبيه لا تؤثر علينا انظمهنا
الدفاعيه قويه واتخذنا في المنظمه
الاجراءات اللازمه لمواجهه اي تحديات
والعدو سيفشلوا في تنفيذ اي عمل عمليه